H
McENANY.
AND ALSO JOINING US TODAY.
NEWLY RELEASED VIDEO AND
HEARTBREAKING STORIES EMERGING
TODAY HIGHLIGHTING AMERICA'S
CRIME CRISIS AND WHY SOME
VICTIMS ARE BLAMING PROGRESSIVE
POLICIES FOR IT.
NEW VIDEO FROM NEW YORK CITY
SHOWS A GANG OF ALLEGEDLY WOMEN
WEARING NEON GREEN LEOTARDS
TERRORIZING VICTIMIZE ON THE
SUBWAY.
THEY BEAT TEENS AT RANDOM.
THE VIDEO SHOWS THAT GANG
TOSSING AROUND ONE OF THE GIRLS
AND PUNCHING THE OTHER
REPEATEDLY IN THE FACE.
THE NEW YORK POST REPORTS THE
MOTHER OF ONE OF THOSE VICTIMS
HAS SUGGESTED THAT THE STATE
LACKS BILL REFORM LAWS ARE TO
BLAME FOR A TEXT LIKE THIS AND
THEY AND SHE ACCUSED THE STATES
DEMOCRATS OF MAKING THESE
RIDICULOUS LAWS AND LETTING
SAVAGES WATCH THE WALK THE
STREETS WITH NOTHING BUT A SLAP
ON THE WRIST.
ANOTHER VICTIM IS ALSO PUSHING
BACK ON ANOTHER DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKER.
YOU MAY ALSO REMEMBER THIS VIDEO
ELIZABETH GOMEZ A MOTHER OF TWO,
BRUTALLY BEATEN IN THE SUBWAY AS
SHE WAS ON HER WAY TO WORK.
SHE WAS DRAGGED ACROSS THE
PLATFORM AND REPEATEDLY KICKED
AND PUNCHED AND THEN JUST DAYS
LATER, THE DEMOCRATIC COUNCIL
WOMAN WHO REPRESENTS HER
DISTRICT WE DID THIS, SUBWAY
VIOLENCE IS A ONE IN A MILLION
EVENT.
AS A BELIEVER IN A VIOLENCE FREE
NEW YORK CITY, I STILL THINK
THAT IS ONE TOO MANY.
LET'S NOT LET FEAR MONGERING
POLITICIANS AND CORPORATE MEDIA
OUTLETS SCARE US INTO THINKING
WE HAVE A DANGEROUS SCARY PUBLIC
TRANSIT SYSTEM.
WATCH HOW SHE REACTED TO THE
COUNCILWOMAN'S TWEET STREET
EARLIER TODAY ON FOX.
>> HOW COULD SHE EVEN SAY THAT
WHEN 99 PERCENT OF THESE
VIOLENCE ARE COMING FROM THE
SUBWAYS.
THERE IS NO HELP THERE, THERE'S
HARDLY ANY KIND OF CAMERAS THERE
ARE SO HOW COULD SHE EVEN SAY
THAT?
WE ARE JUST KIND OF MAKING THESE
THINGS UP?
THE SUBWAY IS DANGEROUS PLACE.
PEOPLE ARE THROWING EACH OTHER
ONTO THE TRACKS IN THEIR GETTING
SLICED IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
RIDE.
HOW COULD THEY EVEN SAY
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
SUBWAYS ARE ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS PLACES IN NEW YORK
CITY AND WE NEED LOTS OF CAMERAS
EVEN INSIDE THE DRAINS WE NEED
THE CAMERAS.
>> HARRIS, THIS ATTACK WAS
NAUSEATING AND FRIGHTENING TO
WATCH.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT WAS LIKE
TO ENDURE FOR THAT POOR MOTHER
OF TWO.
WE KNOW BECAUSE WE REPORT FACTS
HERE ON THIS NETWORK THAT THE
VIOLENT SUBWAY FELONIES ARE
ALMOST 50 PERCENT, ARRESTS ARE
DOWN 12 PERCENT YET THE COPS
HAVE BEEN DEFENDED HERE AND THAT
SEVEN OUT OF TEN NEW YORKERS
WANT MORE POLICE ON THE SUBWAYS.
THIS MOTHER WAS CRYING ON AIR,
AND BEGGING ESSENTIALLY FOR
POLITICIANS TO DO SOMETHING.
THE COUNCILWOMAN REPRESENTING
HER SAID IT'S A ONCE IN A
MILLION EVENT THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> FOR THE COUNCILWOMAN, THE
SUBWAY IS THE NEW FOUR
DEMOCRATS, THEY WON'T GO THERE.
THE WHITE HOUSE WON'T GO TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER TO ASSESS WHAT
THE PROBLEM IS, AND THEY WON'T
GO TO THE SUBWAY.
REMEMBER IN THE FIRST EARLY DAYS
OF THE THEN JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO THE NEW CITY MAYOR, ERIC
ADAMS, HE ALSO SAID SOMETHING
VERY SIMILAR.
DON'T DISPARAGE THE REPUTATION
OF THE SUBWAY SYSTEM AND ITS
SAFETY AND THEN WE HAD SOME
SITUATIONS THAT GO ALONG AND
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT PUTTING
UP CAMERAS AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
THAT ALL GOES AWAY BECAUSE AS
YOU SAID, THE MONEY WENT AWAY
FOR THE PROTECTION DOWN THERE.
THE POLICE IN GENERAL
SPECIFICALLY I SHOULD SAY.
SO FOR THE COUNCILWOMAN TO SAY
ONE IN A MILLION, IT PROBABLY
FEELS LIKE THAT TO HER.
WHAT SHE THINKS AS THAT HER
CONSTITUENTS ARE STUPID AND SHE
CAN PREACH TO THEM AND CHANGE
THEIR REALITY WHAT IS THE WORD
THEY'D LIKE TO USE?
SHE CAN REIMAGINE SHE CAN
REIMAGINE LIFE FOR TRAVELERS,
BUT YOU KNOW WHEN IT'S GOING TO
GET WORSE?
IT'S IN THE 40s AND RAINING.
GIVE US ANOTHER TEN OR 15 DAYS
AND THAT RAIN WILL TURN COLDER,
MAYBE EVEN JUST KNOW, WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT WE KNOW IT'S NOT GOING
IN THE 90-DEGREE DIRECTION.
SO YOU WILL HAVE MORE PEOPLE
SUBTERRANEAN TAKING THE SUBWAY.
IT WANT BE ONE IN A MILLION EVEN
IN HER FRAGILE.
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO BE DISCARDED, BEING TOLD
THAT YOU DON'T MATTER, THAT YOUR
WIFE LIFE IS NOT WORTH
REPRESENTING.
I WAS IN HIS CABIN HE WAS SAYING
HE HAD BEEN HELD UP ONCE AGAIN
POINT IN HIS REALLY LONG CAREER
IN DRIVING.
HE SAID HE'S NEVER FELT MORE IN
DANGER THAN HE DOES NOW.
I KNOW YOU DROVE A CAB FOR OVER
TEN YEARS HERE IN THE CITY.
WHAT IF YOU SEE CHANGE?
>> PROBABLY LIFE AROUND YOU ON
THE GROUND HAS DEFINITELY
DETERIORATED.
WHEN I DRIVE AT CAP 12 HOURS A
DAY, MAYBE I'M NOT THE BEST GUY
TO COME TO ON VIOLENCE.
BUT WHAT WE WATCHED AS A WHOLE
AS A SOCIETY THAT SLEPT ITSELF
GO BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
PROGRESSIVE POLITIES AND
DEMONSTRATED MORE EMPATHY FOR
THE CRIMINAL THAN THE
LAW-ABIDING CITIZEN.
WHEN WE WERE KIDS, WE PLAYED A
GAME CALLED COPS AND ROBBERS.
THE COPS WHERE THE GOOD GUYS AND
THE ROBBERS WERE ALWAYS THE BAD
GUYS.
IN THE MODERN VERSION OF THAT,
WE ARE SHOWING MORE EMPATHY IN
THE PAST TO YEARS FOR THE
ROBBERS.
WE ARE LEADING THEM OUT OF JAIL
IN DOING SO IN THE NAME OF
PROTECTING MINORITY COMMUNITIES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE HIGH RATES,
WHO ARE THEY HARMING,
SPECIFICALLY THE MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
MANY OF THESE ARE WOMEN.
HOW MANY WOMEN DO WE NEED TO
WATCH KIDS STABBED OR THROWN ON
AS SUBWAY TRACKS?
EVERY DAY WE GET ON TV AND IT'S
ALMOST LIKE PEOPLE ARE AND IT'S
EVERY DAY, IT'S DISCUSSING.
>> YOU ARE NOT SAFE AT SEVEN IN
THE MORNING RUNNING IN CENTRAL
PARK YOU'RE NOT SAFE TAKING THE
SUBWAY AT 3:30 A.M. TO YOUR
GRAVEYARD SHIFT.
WE MENTION POLICIES AND WHAT
DISTURBS ME SO MUCH AND WHAT IS
SO FRIGHTENING IS THE NOTION
THAT BECAUSE OF THESE REGRESSIVE
POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN PUT INTO
PLACE, IT WILL TAKE LIKELY YEARS
TO RESTORE ORDER TO RESTORE
POLICE RANKS, TO RESTORE SUPPORT
FOR LAW-ENFORCEMENT AND LAW AND
ORDER IN AND OUT OF THE SYSTEM
AND YET ALL IT TAKES IS ONE
INSTANT FOR A GUNSHOT TO TAKE A
MOTHER BIRD FOR A FIST TO
SHATTER YOUR OR SOMEBODY TO BE
SLASHED WITHIN 18 INCHES SCAR.
HOW MANY INSTANTS DO WE HAVE WE
DON'T HAVE THAT MANY.
>> JIMMY JUST TALKED ABOUT WOMEN
POTENTIALLY BEING STABBED THERE
WAS A WOMAN HE WAS STABBED TO
DEATH WITH A PAIR OF SCISSORS BY
A MAN, GUESS WHO WAS THE LONE
BOAT TO GET THIS MAN AND CAN
MEET COMMUTE HIS SENTENCE?
A GUY NAMED JOHN FEDERMAN WHO
HAPPENS TO BE THE DEMOCRAT
NOMINEE FOR SENATE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS SAME MAN WANTS TO AND OPEN
CARRY FORT LAW-ABIDING MEN AND
WOMEN WHO JUST WANT A GUN TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES IN HIGH CRIME
JURISDICTIONS WHICH HAPPEN TO BE
WITH DEMOCRAT.
NOT JUST VICTIMS, BUT VOTERS
WILL HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE.
70 TO PERCENT, CRIME.
CRIME IS THE REASON MEN MANDELA
BOTTOMS IS TRAILING THIS.
JOHN FEDERMAN IS WITHIN A SINGLE
DIGIT OF LOSING WHO WANTS TO ADD
1500 COPS TO THE BEACH.
CRIME IS THE NEW EDUCATION.
I THINGS EDUCATION IS IMPORTANT,
BUT CRIME IS THE REASON THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO LOSE IN A
BALLOT, AND 35 DAYS.
>> PERFECT SEGUE TO END YOUR
INTERNET AGGREGATE COMPANY AS
YOU HAVE DISCOVERED THESE
RESULTS FIRST HAND.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN FIVE
YEARS AND EVALUATE HOW PEOPLE
FEEL.
YES, IT IS THE FIRST TIME WE SEE
CRIME AT THE TOP OF THE LIST
WITH THE ECONOMY.
SINCE WHEN WE DO THAT SCRAPING
OF THE VOICES OF AMERICANS,
ALMOST 5 MILLION DATA POINTS
JUST IN THE LAST 30 DAYS.
OVERWHELMINGLY, CRIME IS AT THE
VERY TOP, SO IT'S NO LONGER
SOMETHING FOR LOCAL POLITICS
IT'S PART OF NATIONAL POLITICS,
AND I KNOW THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
SAYING IN KIND OF SOUNDING THE
ALARM.
CRIME IS AT THE BALLOT, YES IT
IS, BUT MAY BE A LITTLE TOO LATE
AFTER RECEIVING ALL THE CASES
AND HORRIFIC VIDEOS.
I HAD NEVER FELT UNSAFE IN NEW
YORK UNTIL THE LAST TO YEARS.
>> WHEN YOU ARE IN ARE ANY OF
THEM.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PARTY OF
LAW AND ORDER AS TO BE.
AND THAT MESSAGING ALIGNS WITH
THAT.
THAT'S WHERE WE SEE THE TIGHT
SENATE RACES, BUT HERE IS THE
THING WITH MINORITIES.
THAT WOMAN, MISSUS GOMEZ, SHE
WAS GOING TO WORK, SHE IS A
MOTHER, AND THE FACT THAT I CAN
NO LONGER TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION HAS AFFECTED THE
ECONOMICS OF THE FAMILY WE WANT
TO BE INCLUSIVE AND WELCOMING
OF.
THIS HAS A BACKWARDS EFFECT FOR
ALL AROUND AND THOSE THAT ARE
MOST VULNERABLE WHICH ARE THOSE
VOTERS THAT ARE GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT IN 35 DAYS